when i start alibaba my parents worry my
wife worry my friends were in my
teachers supporting my students where
everybody worked the idea that i could
hire so quickly and invest and build
this worldwide company
was fascinating to me but i was really
busy the most important thing about your
first job out of school is to pick a
place where you think you're gonna
you're where you're learning per unit
time is gonna be very high wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get the seven best
lessons from elon musk jeff bezos and
other billionaire entrepreneurs enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one protect your reputation with
jack ma like any entrepreneur
when you start a business
you start to worry and people around you
worry much more than you do
when i start alibaba my parents worry my
wife worry my friends were in my
teacher's world my students where
everybody worry and they worry about a
lot of things the only thing that i
worry
is that
i should not disappoint the people who
believe in me
and when we study the alibaba we have a
lot of things people worry you know when
we study alibaba say hey
you don't have a payment you don't have
a trust people do not believe in online
they believe in face to face
meeting and government does not support
internet nobody supported e-commerce how
could you do it
i think
as an entrepreneur
if everything is ready
that does not need you
because nothing is ready that needs
entrepreneurship for counterfeit things
of course
there are lot
at the beginning
but you have to fix it
so in the past 15 years we spent a lot
of time because you have to making sure
the customer feels safe
happy
the brand if you're happy
your reputation is the repetition your
reputation is the best otherwise the
people say i sell on the site and my
things were copied and stolen
so we
using a lot of ways to do that today
more than a hundred thousand
brands
partner with us lesson number two keep
doing better with bill gates within a
year of going public i think uh there's
some fortune cover that says the deal
that made bill gates 360 million or some
weird thing like that right how did it
change your life or it didn't change
your life at all well that whole period
of time was amazing because
i was hiring people as fast as i could i
brought in steve ballmer who was very
good at that and and he was helping out
you know we had a sense of urgency that
we wanted to lead the way
there was this graphics interface thing
with windows that we wanted to do so i
was super busy
and the idea that i could
hire so quickly and invest and build
this worldwide company
was fascinating to me but i was really
busy so you know if some friend had
tried to call me uh you know i i
wouldn't have had too much time for that
i was really into building this company
and i was
going out and telling people about the
magic of software which was good for
microsoft but also helping them
understand the opportunities and the
huge change agent that software and
eventually software plus the internet
would
would become so i was having fun it was
amazing but i always thought hey
you know we're one step away from not
you know leading here we gotta gotta
keep doing better lesson number three
take charge with oprah winfrey
empowerment is authority
it is a sign permission slip to actually
seize the day
it's the process of getting stronger and
more confident and more engaged and to
be empowered is to move to the world
without any kind of fear or any kind of
apology and with these gifts comes an
even deeper privilege i believe and that
is the ability to take charge of your
own life to own yourself and claim your
rights and here's what i know for sure
that to whom much is given much is
expected
and i have been given so much
i've earned it
i've been blessed with it
but i've been given a lot
and that's why i've chosen to use my
life to lift other people up lesson
number four take the time to learn with
jeff bezos just find something that
you're passionate about i would
definitely on the career advice side the
most important thing
about your first
job out of school is to pick a place
where you think you're going to where
you're learning per unit time is going
to be very high you can optimize for a
bunch of variables and it can get very
confusing you know where is the location
you know what's the
salary going to be and all those things
are worth considering they're all
important but make sure you pull back
after you've done your analysis and say
am i also picking the place that i
believe my learning per unit time is
going to be the fastest and you learn
much more from a best practices company
than you do you learn no matter where
you go so if you go work for somebody
you're like god these people are all
crazy this is insane you'll learn a lot
of negative lessons that you can use
later and you cannot do those things but
that process of elimination method takes
a long time
so it's better to try and find a place
that has really high hiring standards
some of the basics especially you know a
place that's trying to recruit only the
you know the you know a is higher a's
and b's higher c's and c is higher ds so
you've got to hire only a's and you need
to pick a company that's doing those
kinds of fundamental practices well
because then you'll learn so much it'll
set you up to do other things so i would
say that's probably the best career
advice i give lesson number five go big
a go bigger with grant cardone when 2008
happened i had nothing to do with 2008 i
had two businesses and i was starting to
buy real estate and i was not buying the
real estate to cause the problem in this
country any of you remember when lehman
collapsed
your business if you were in business
your business probably got hurt
i wasn't doing the mortgage-backed
securities i wasn't doing the no money
down houses
you know i wasn't selling that stuff i
wasn't doing mass development on the
backs of the bank
uh with bad loans
but
because i lived in america
and i was doing business at the time i
got greatly affected by that my first
two businesses got cut in half and my
real estate was frozen up i owed 52
million dollars to a bank that went
upside down new bank came in they
started making demands on me i ended up
in a lawsuit aren't there a bunch of
lawyers in here yeah i ended up i ended
up in one of these crazy lawsuits where
the guy was going under he had done some
things wrong and he decided to pull me
down with it it was a frivolous lawsuit
that was costing me 200 grand a month to
fund i had never been involved in a
lawsuit in my career
so that being said um
i looked at that situation and said hey
what did i do wrong here
like i always look
at how am i responsible responsible
able to respond that is the definition
of responsible able to respond
now in my case i was being forced to
respond
it wasn't a lot of able in it
so uh
but the one thing that i walked away
with was i had a baby on the way i just
been married i just got married maybe
three years before that so the marriage
was very new
we were we were really still in the
honeymoon phases of our marriage
not really understanding
who we were as a team my wife and i new
baby coming along
i lived in los angeles i lived in a
beautiful house up in the hills
uh overlooking all of l.a and i pretty
much thought my life was great until
2008 happened now i'm taking a second to
get you to to what i want you to hear i
didn't plan on 2008 i didn't think about
a lehman collapse i didn't know
40 million people were going to go
upside down in their homes i did not
know it would affect me i didn't know
one of my industries was the automobile
dealers i was working with automotive
meal dealers around the united states
that was my primary business
i was making a couple million bucks a
year i didn't know
9 000 car dealers would go out of
business
who would plan on any of that
now what's that got to do with today
who in their business plan had coved as
part of your business plan
let us know in the chat put put it put a
no in the chat if you didn't have a plan
for that yeah
yeah i need to see 316. i need to see
one
one guy in here say oh yeah i planned on
mask
oh yeah i had
i had myself going out one week buying
400 worth of toilet paper
okay
uh
oh yeah in 2020 by the way how many of
you in 2020 january 1st you're like this
is going to be the best year of my life
oh yeah
yeah everybody gave that up on march
23rd the entire nation of america
gave up
surrender 2020.
look the news the media
by april was saying 2020 is over how
many of you heard that
i'm throwing 20 20 away fortune 500
companies 100 companies carnival cruise
lines general motors ford motor company
like mass companies were like i'm done
i'm tapping out
this year's over
wall street every day i'm watching
bloomberg right now wall street's like
hey just throw away all the earnings for
2020 let's reboot for 2021 the entire
nation surrendered
your kids aren't going to schools
you didn't plan on that did you
see this is the problem with the concept
i think i saw somewhere in your promo go
big or
go home
go big or go home ain't nothing at home
folks
there ain't nothing at your house you're
not gonna make your business work at
home
okay go big or go home or home you need
to scratch that out and say look i got
to go big or i got to go bigger because
going home cannot be a choice now and
the whole country went home we've been
quarantined you're going to have 10
million probably 8 to 10 million
bankruptcies by the end of this year the
the other shoe has not dropped yet the
stock market's going crazy the rich are
getting richer and and i don't include
us on this call as the rich the rich
will get richer
okay you why because they think big
they think big they never waste a crisis
and we are in a crisis
and the crisis if you were in trouble
before covid you are in more trouble
today and the reason we're in trouble is
because people in this country are
satisfied complacent
comfortable these are the enemy so if
you can take anything away from me it's
like look you have you and your wife you
and your husband you and your kids must
give up ideas of comfort hey man how you
doing buddy good how are you you got a
book coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number six don't reason by analogy with
elon musk if you want to do something
really innovative you have to apply a
sort of first principles analysis
not and don't don't reason by analogy
analogies
are referencing the past um
so
first principles means you you look at
the most fundamental truths in a
particular arena
and the things that
really are
almost indisputably correct
and you reason up from there to a
conclusion
and and if you if you see that that
conclusion is at odds with with what
people generally believe then you have
an opportunity
now you can't operate like that on all
things because it takes too much mental
horsepower so most of your life you have
to operate by reasoning by analogy but
if you really want to invade you must
reason for first principles to identify
the problem and lesson number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is recognize other people's skills
with mark cuban being treating people
equally is not is not the same
is not recognizing who they truly are
and taking advantage of their skills you
know
and i've learned that through sin i've
learned that through all this and you
know like sin and i talk we'll be a much
better organization i'll be a better
exec i'll be a better investor i'll be a
better um
shark um because i recognize that you
know treating people equally is not the
same as treating them recognizing their
skills and their differences and for
this for this audience it's critically
important
you know
and i think there's an opportunity now
and i know hopefully you know people
like me will recognize that the old
white guys now newly old white guys that
are in positions of power
that
there are things that you can do that i
can't do that there are things you see
that i don't see
there are
opportunities that you can create
that i can't create
you know we were trying to sell to the
black community
through the mavs
with
multiple white men
we were trying to sell to moms with
multiple white men
it's not that they're not capable it's
not that they're not skilled
it's just everybody brings something
different to the table and as an
entrepreneur you have to recognize what
the differences are that you bring to
the table and you have to be brutally
honest with yourself right you can't lie
to yourself like we all lie to ourselves
as entrepreneurs but those differences
can be part of your unique skill set
like i talked about earlier and now i'm
finally starting to recognize those
things
and you know the one thing i know it's
going to make me a load more money now
i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
what is your decision-making process or
thinking when it comes to investing your
time your money your energy sure
it's very important because time is the
most valuable thing you have is one make
sure where you're putting your time and
energy
is something you want to do
not just because you're exploring with
people you don't like or a business you
don't like or a situation you don't like
time is so valuable try and speak if
you're speaking to people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you can do something with to do
something great not just make money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone just to make
money then it means you've already
decided to take a portion of your time
to make these papers that are backed up
by nothing but will buy stuff
to call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great possessions
could you give them away
if you had any possession you could give
it away hey great it was a possession
and you moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away
then it possesses you today people come
to you all the time for money i assume
everywhere you go people say by the way
i have this thing you should invest in
but i have a couple myself i'll mention
later no i'm not just kidding no a
couple things you should invest in or
things you should give money to so how
do you resist it you have some person
who says no for you or how do you do
that
let many people uh many people say no
well once you picked what you care about
if somebody has something that can make
a difference in global health we're
super interested and you know we have
staff of 1500 people
and if it's to do with global health
some of those people will come out and
talk through with you whatever your
innovation is and how we can partner
with you on that you know so that's
clearly in our area if it is something
that can substantially improve k-12
education then we're going to be very
interested in it if people are asking
outside of those things then you know
fortunately you can say no because focus
is is key to philanthropy you can use
your gifts that's what you're really
here to do
to illuminate
the darkness in our world
so this is what i also know that this
this this moment in time
this is your
time
to rise
[Music]
it is
even though
you can't go anywhere you can't stand in
line at starbucks you can't go to a
party you can go to any place without
everywhere you turn people are talking
about how bad things are how terrible it
is and this is what i know the problem
is everybody is meeting hysteria with
more hysteria
and then we just are all becoming
hysterical and it's getting worse
what i've learned all these years is
that we're not supposed to match it or
even get locked into resisting or
pushing against it we're supposed to see
this moment in time for what it is we're
supposed to see through it and then
transcend it
that is how you overcome hysteria
and that is how you overcome the sniping
at one another the trolling the
mean-spirited partisanship on both sides
of the aisle the divisiveness the
injustices and the out and out hatred
you use it use this moment
to encourage you to embolden you and to
literally
push you into the rising
of your life
and to borrow a phrase from my beloved
mentor maya angelou just like moons and
like sons with the certainty of tides
just like the hopes springing high
you
will rise what inspired me was um
an is continues to be what continues to
inspire me
is a
primal and fundamental desire
to fulfill
the highest expression
of myself as a human being
i don't want to die
not having
completely
burnt out
every
single possibility of my humanity
i just i just wanna when i leave this
planet i want everybody
did that
used it all up not another thing i could
do there was another person i could have
given of myself to there wasn't another
deed i could have done there wasn't
anything that you just wanted you want
to say i want to fill it up you want to
take this whole human existence which
when you think about it godfrey is
really pretty damn miraculous it is it
is it is when you think about what it
means to be a human being on the planet
earth right now that's pretty awesome
so i just want to i want to i want to
take that to the max i want to say no
need to come back as a human
angel status or maybe i just blank out
the word doubt
um
so uh no i mean i tritoli frank i
doubted us too so i thought we you know
had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right you know
i mean there were times uh
that i was told like
uh because i was taking the money that i
earned from from paypal and enrolling
into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all it wasn't the
intention but um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon 1.
um and uh
so but a lot of times i was you know i
people would tell me this joke like how
do you make a small fortune in the rock
industry you start with a large one is
the punch line
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so
so
anyway um and it was it almost came true
[Music]
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to save the company we also then had to
win the nasa cargo resupply contract um
so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later or towards the
end of 2008 those are the two key things
that that saved spacex otherwise we
would have we would have you know
not made it so
um
so hey i think those those doubters were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately uh
vader smiled upon us and brought us to
this day by the way getting it wrong
isn't that bad that's the other thing
when when we make mistakes and we've
made doozies like the fire phone and
many other things that just didn't work
out i can i could we don't have enough
time for me to list all of our failed
experiments but the big winners
pay for thousands of failed experiments
so you try something like prime and it
was very expensive at the beginning it
costs us a lot of money because what
happens when you offer a free
all-you-can-eat buffet who shows up to
the buffet first
the heavy eaters
it's scary it's like oh my god did i
really say as many prawns as you can eat
and
so
that is what happened but sure but
surely we could see the trend lines we
could see that you know the different
all kinds of customers were coming and
they appreciated that service people ask
me why e-commerce so successful in china
our company alone is much bigger than
amazon
why e-commerce in china
one of the reasons why e-commerce in
china success successful because china
had a terrible infrastructure of
commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have so many like walmart came out
everywhere
it's it's just a terrible
retail system in china when internet
e-commerce come people love it so so
efficient
why china mobile phone you know grow
much faster than america america and
europe have such a great such a great
system of telephone we don't have 10 of
them
right amount like 100 family can only
have one telephone that days where
mobile come we love that we just go that
so there is a leapfrog
we don't have that rules or laws most of
the government offices they don't know
how to make rules laws for internet
because nobody realizes what is internet
look like so that leave a chance to grow
fast
europe
very interesting you have such a perfect
rules or loss
then everything you do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about the thing they do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about they start to worry when they
worry they make a rules loss
when we have a problems we start to
solve the problems
then think about rules or laws
you have a problem like make rules a
loss
so
i worry about europe
i worry
i worry about the worries of the europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry why europe worry about
right you don't have solutions for
artificial intelligence oh you know
they're going to destroy a lot of things
the human life
forget it
let me tell you artificial intelligence
i think
we alibaba using artificial intelligence
to arrest and catch a lot of thieves
my theory i told my engineers i said
now
when you love somebody you may not have
reasons
but when you
hate somebody
you have logic and reasons
we have logic and reasons machine can
always do better than that
so
we have a trillions of dollar
transaction on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
1 billion users using that there are so
many cheatings
human being cannot do it so we teach
machines to catch all the thieves
machines never forget
no matter how smart you are one person
can create 10 ways of cheating you are
the smartest person in the world
but we teach the machine
every way everything we just discover
from other people the machine can
remember over a hundred thousand ways of
cheating when you start the cheating
machine find you
so
one way
bad guys using artificial intelligence
doing bad things other thing we using
artificial intelligence to catch bad
guys
so there is always in a young balance
how you see the world if you see
technology revolution is a problem i'm
sorry to say the problem just started
if you think it's an opportunity
the opportunity just started the only
thing is
your mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
by the way
all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready
everything's perfect
why they need you
because there is worries because there's
a problems because of there's no this
know that that is your opportunity that
is our opportunity and
keep on that
you believing you can do something
little by little 10 years later you'll
be different that's that's that's who we
are
companies are learning organisms
and
you can make decisions that either make
it so that you learn faster or you learn
slower and you know in a lot of ways
building a company is like following the
scientific method right you try a bunch
of different hypotheses
and if you set up the experiments well
then you kind of learn what to do and
again that's that's an important
philosophy so there are all these
different decisions that we make inside
the company
you know everything down to
um really empowering individual
engineers we invest in this huge
um testing framework right at any given
point in time there aren't there's not
just one version of facebook running in
the world right there's probably tens of
thousands of versions running because
engineers here have the power to um to
try out an idea
and and and ship it to you know maybe 10
000 people or 100 000 people and then
they get a readout on how
that version of what they did whether it
was
a change to you know show better content
to news feed or ui change or some new
feature
they get a readout on how uh that
version performed compared to the
baseline version of facebook that we
have on everything that we care about
how how connected people are
you know how much people are sharing and
how much they say that they're finding
meaningful content uh business metrics
like how much revenue we make and
engagement of the overall community and
you know by running tens of thousands of
different experiments and putting the
power in people's hands to try all these
different things you can imagine we just
make so much more progress than we could
if every change had to be approved by me
right or any every idea had to come from
from management so i do think there's
something very deep about building this
you know learning culture and moving
quickly towards that that just helps you
get ahead over time there are a lot of
good ideas there are a lot of good ideas
there are a lot of good ideas
translating a good idea
into a great product
is
unbelievably hard
there are so many details people accuse
steve of stealing you know the macintosh
from xerox you know with the alto
computer i was at xerox park so i used
the alto a lot
finishing the alto
and turning that into the macintosh
was enormously complicated and you there
were so many things that had to be done
that xerox had not done there were a few
good ideas in uh in the xerox machine
but steve would translate good ideas not
always his good ideas
but he would translate good ideas
into finished product
unlike anyone in our industry you'd have
to i mean henry ford didn't invent the
car
but he made it cheap and he made it
popular and he made it accessible to the
american people steve would translate
good ideas into finished
brilliant product we probably spend less
money in marketing than any
company our size in the world
we have a tiny marketing department and
everyone says why oracle's you know all
about sales and marketing
we are the largest employer of mit and
caltech engineers in the world
we are the largest employer of stanford
and
harvard and cmu mathematicians in the
world
we are overwhelmingly dominated by
engineering at oracle
the idea that we are a sales and
marketing company which people will
sometimes will write about quite often
is ludicrous on the face of it
because
all of our customers who buy oracle
already have it
and if you already have oracle there's
nothing a salesman can tell you about
how great it is to make you buy more
ge already uses it the defense
department always you already use it all
of our customers 98 of our sales or more
are to existing oracle customers
if we don't have the right product
people don't buy more
we will before the acquisition we spend
three billion dollars a year in software
engineering
the company is all about engineering
it's the only thing that works
how have you hired your team uh and what
do you look for when you bring people on
if you think about it
you know i started the company when i
was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important right or
else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself right and
and and the company so you know we
invest in
in people who we think are just really
talented even if they haven't done that
thing before and you know that applies
to people who are fresh out of
university as well as you know people
like um you know the cfo who took the
company public had not taken a company
public before right and a lot of his
background was in um you know production
uh development at genentech before so
you know just focus on really talented
people and i think one of the things i
want to share with the values the six
values about the two values very unique
in alibaba which i think the whole world
should think about we put custom number
one in priority number two shareholder
number three most companies
in the wall street they put the
shareholder number one i said
each
customer is the most important if you
serve them well they pay you the money
and the second important is colleagues
why the colleagues get together because
they want to serve the customers if they
do not cost serve the customers why we
get it together
right so if the customer happy in price
happy the shareholders will be happy i
feel like you always
seem to swing for the fences in general
it's just sort of a new way of framing
it but i have to ask if you are swinging
for the fences
what if you miss
well hopefully uh you get more than one
swing okay swings
either at the same problem like you know
multiple malaria vaccine constructs so
that you know if you have two or three
the combined chance of success is much
higher or
that you're working in multiple areas
not just one area right you know in
climate for example
i have a company that's uh trying to
make a nuclear reactor
that would be very cheap and that would
have safety so that the public
would be very accepting of it now
you know even i realize that's high risk
you know less than 50 percent chance all
that comes together and yet
uh
if it did
and the only reason i'm involved is it
would really help with climate uh let us
generate electricity without any
greenhouse gases the winner in ai
controls the world china puts together a
future plan
saying you know whoever dominates an ai
and they're subsidizing you know tencent
alibaba et cetera yeah right and that's
right they're they're that's they know
it's a race it is a race we cut our
office of technology and science to one
person who was an assistant to peter
thiel
that's where we stand so when we talk
about infrastructure jobs you know
robots are built in germany and they're
getting buyed by chinese companies in
some respects and i think some japanese
companies bought as well
we don't build robots here very well
right i just invested in my first
robotics company hirebots that puts
robots into companies um they're in
kansas city i think it is now um
but they
they lease and rent and sell robots into
all these different types of
circumstances to replace people right
but i had to learn i'm not saying it's a
good thing or bad thing it's going to
happen with or without me but i wanted
to learn what was going on those
building up a robotics
industry here
investing in our ai industry here that's
the new infrastructure yeah because if
we don't do it and china or russia win
those wars
we're sol right we're out of luck right
and so when we talk about the price of
assets going up
when
if you're hiring you know if you're
talking about intellectual assets if
you're hiring like we were just saying
the price is skyrocketing people you
know montreal has become the the center
of the universe for computer vision um
it's not us-based schools that are
dominating any longer in those areas
we've got a lot of smart kids in mit all
different schools right and kids are
starting to realize it's a place for
them to go and i'm out there telling
people the first trillionaire is going
to come from somebody who who comes up
with something really unique in ai as a
general matter as a one piece of
specific finance
financial advice
i would say you know avoid credit cards
just forget about them
we're in various businesses that issue
credit cards the american public loves
credit cards but if you start revolving
debt on credit cards you're going to be
paying
uh 18 or 20
and
you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at eighteen or
twenty percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at eight or eighteen or twenty
percent over time you know if you can
find anybody that's good that will
borrow from you but you don't wanna be
on the side of the equation that's
always behind in life
uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the expenses roll
in but but those were my tools to work
with but it was only because i was ahead
of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying 18 or 20 percent interest on it
you will never you know you'll never get
out of it so the trick
i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know and
and that's true in financial matters as
well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and i get
about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems
and there are two reasons why they have
terrible problems one is
a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in
they run up bills they can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh uh in terms of protecting people
against that that's just plain bad luck
but
the other one is from people who run up
credit card debt and uh they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been through
bankruptcy once before and they owe a
whole bunch of money and they can't they
can't even pay the interest let alone
pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable catastrophic illness is not
but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better
it's way easier to stay out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and uh i will guarantee you if you
run a big credit card that you will be
in trouble
uh probably the rest of your life in
terms of
uh your financial situation on the other
hand if you get ahead of the game
uh
even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're
people owe you money or equities owe you
ownership
you'll be way out of the game compared
to paying it
being always being paying
your creditors every month so
my advice to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it i
was terrified for example
both in high school and college i don't
know when it started
but i became terrified of public
speaking and uh i just couldn't do it i
mean i and so i arranged all of my
classes so i never had to
do any public speaking and i got to
colombia and i saw an ad in the paper
uh for dale carnegie course
and i went down it was somewhere in the
mid-40s and i gave the guy a check for a
hundred dollars and i went back and
stopped payment i lost my nerve and then
i came out
i got out of columbia actually when i
was 20 and i came out to start selling
securities in omaha
and i realized i had to get up and be
able to get up in front of people i
couldn't go through life this way so i
saw an ad again in the uh local paper
that there was a dale carnegie of course
being given
i went down and i gave the fellow 100 in
cash and
i became associated with 30 other people
in the class we couldn't stand up in
front of a group and say our own name i
mean it was we were it was pathetic but
that class changed my life in a big way
as a matter of fact
they used to give a pencil every week
for whoever did the most with what they
learned the previous week and during
that class i proposed to my wife and she
accepted that i won the pencil that week
so it it's important i mean there's
certain you've got to be able to
communicate in life and it's enormously
important and probably the schools to
some extent underemphasize that i mean
you get started going for an mba and
people think it's kind of beneath them
to teach about communication but if you
if you can't communicate if you can't
talk to other people and get across your
ideas or write you know you know you
you're giving up your potential and uh
you know anybody that's got a career
potential backs i i guarantee it'll be
150 of x if they uh if they really learn
how to communicate well so that was that
was a big
a part of really succeeding in my career
how did you get through like tactically
to a sale in the encyclopedia world like
people don't want to hear from you so
like how do you overcome that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was out for three and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview they told
you all you could possibly make off
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing when you got in the
field you remember parts of it you knock
on doors you're not quite sure of
yourself a lot of dirts are close in
your face but what happens after a while
you start getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do that'll make it
better but when you go back the next day
with your other sales people what you
see what you do what did i say
so let's say knock on 100 door skin into
one give 10 presentations to sell one
book but then when you get better and
better at it through your experiences
and losses along the way it sharpens you
up where all of a sudden i got to a
point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order commission only but i believe that
i could do that i believe that colleges
were the best set of books because a
high school student could read it it
wasn't like a college manual you had to
read and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe that
what you're doing is good is going to
benefit somebody and you learn as you go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people don't know these things
look someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're under
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes at their eyebrows looks
like you're looking at the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile is the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing because when you smile
everything changes people change even
after you had done your thing there was
still an eighth course to make sure that
yahoo itself was on track do you know
what that was about yeah they were
screwing everything up you know i mean
look they had they had an opportunity to
dominate um streaming media they also
owned at the same time the patent to
cost per click yeah
right now google's entire business to
this day
is built around
pay-per-click rather than not calling
pay-per-click yeah
so they had the entire patent for
pay-per-click
had they just said sorry google
you can't use it
there would be no google
instead they said yeah 133 million
dollars and give us some stock
they were just too nice
right which blinded them in a lot of
respects and i remember walking in with
a 32 million dollar sale
saying okay we're going to do streaming
we're going to sell all this company's
content you know it's worth 32 million
dollars for us and it's going to pre-up
these other
potential competitors
and um
i forget if it's jerry or tim whoever
said no we don't work that way we don't
preempt competition we just leave it
open
i'm like okay it's time for me to go buy
a basketball team
that's they just they just didn't see
these things and i mean it's a lesson in
your businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass
and you have to figure out how to kick
your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself in your own
business about what your frailties are
someone else is going to find them yahoo
didn't get that yahoo just thought you
know what we're just going to continue
moving forward and we'll just compete
with everybody else and you know there's
we have no other problems
didn't quite work out for them did it no
it did not i'm a student of observation
i i observe things i remember being
being selling cars saying this is stupid
first i learned how to do it right the
customer the 12 steps right and then i'm
like if i do 12 steps with everybody i
can't get 30 units a month
and then i'm like i started skipping
steps right
uh i mean because i wanted i wanted
those 10 car car weeks
and the only way to do that was walk out
there and just start offering people
what they had what they what they were
going to ask me for anyway right can i
get you a price a payment a down payment
a monthly bank can i get you everything
you need right i knew it was just a
matter of about 30 seconds they were
going to ask for it all no doubt so i
just basically intercepted the customer
sped up the processes and and then i'm
like man i i started hitting 30 36 units
31 units in 14 days i'm like this is the
way to do it and then when i lost my job
because the dealer wasn't big enough
didn't think big enough himself didn't
10x
when i left him i didn't have any place
to go
in his company or his organization i
couldn't be a star there
i went out and started teaching it if
you want to learn computer science just
you know knuth wrote the book buy it
okay
uh you know read it and do the problems
for if you really think you know this
thing if you want to learn physics
feinman wrote the book uh just read the
damn book it's all there so that when we
put stuff online
it we don't have anything in online
physics that's any better than feynman's
book honest honestly now it's a little
easier to learn uh you know the guy
makes jokes every 20 minutes or at least
tries to uh and he does more demos and
things so
learning is a weird social phenomena and
so you know our foundation our big
problem is that
the
group that does the worst with online
learning are low-income students because
their notion of why am i learning their
sense of self-confidence the ability to
figure out why i just got stuck because
you know two minuses cancel out and i i
never saw that notation before they just
hit dead ends
all the time
that if you're sitting in your dorm at
stanford you know somebody walks down
and
uh helps you get through it i was
wondering if you have any stock tips for
any of the students you know who are all
trying to
uh make make a little living
i didn't think they taught that at
georgetown
they
now the
the best the best investment i ever met
well
i i bought a book in 1949 by a fellow
named ben graham called the intelligent
investor i i don't remember what i paid
but aside from what i paid for my two
marriage licenses that was the best
investment i ever made
and uh
it's very important to have the right
framework you need
you need
you need to have an approach to
investing
that sound and graham's approach is is
simple
uh but some people
adopt to it and and
which i did immediately and and most
people don't
but if you have the right philosophy
you will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years and and frankly you're most
likely to find them uh
when in periods like five years ago when
we were having the panic i mean that
uh
stocks
sell at silly prices from time to time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices um
and it doesn't take a high iq to figure
out
that they're cheap but it does take a
temperament that's willing to step up
and actually act
i tell people if they're going in the
investment business
if you got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
it yeah i mean i figured out very early
you don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate but you do
have to have the right temperament and
you have to be able to ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts and decide
is this stock which is selling it x
worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if when you don't
find them you don't do anything so
that's my
generalized stock tip no names
with such a great
infrastructure of the internet you have
with the so many people in the world
today know about the internet they're
today but more than 1.7 billion people
are already online
but that time
total china less than like 500 people
using internet
it's difficult
but as i said just in the other room
everybody
when you have a dream you have to dream
globally or you have to win locally
you have to survive today
but you also have to think about the
future
if you do not think about the future if
you do not have a vision for 10 years
later what will you be you will never
have a great people follow you and join
your company
but if you cannot survive
you go nowhere my grandparents would
take me every summer
starting at age four
every summer
kind of to give her a break really um
for the whole summer so i'd be with my
grandparents and on their ranch in
catoola texas which is halfway between
san antonio and laredo
we lived in houston
and so we would make the five-hour drive
out to catoola they'd drop me off spend
a couple of days there then they'd go
back to houston i'd spend the summer and
i went every day to the ranch
with my grandfather to help now a
four-year-old boy
on a ranch
in south texas is not a lot of help
but i didn't know that i thought i was
helping and
and then as i by the time i was 16 i
actually was helping
so i have you know i i can
i can
suture up a prolapsed cow
i can fix windmills
my grandfather was so resourceful
and that he made his own veterinary
needles he would take a little piece of
wire and pound it flat with a
was like a oxy acetylene torch
and then drilled a little hole through
it and then we would do we did all of
our own veterinary work some of the
cattle even survived
and uh
so we had but we had great fun out there
you know um we
built barns and welded things and he
bought a
d6
caterpillar bulldozer
used it was like
1955 model year
for five thousand dollars was completely
broken the gears were stripped and then
we spent you know a whole summer
repairing that the first thing we had to
do to repair it was build a crane to
take the gears out of the transmission
and so
you know what i learned from watching
him was just how resourceful he was he
didn't ever call a repairman he figured
it out spanx started way before i cut
the feet out of my pantyhose that's the
sound bite in the press that everybody's
talked about for almost 20 years but it
actually started
fundamentally on when i was 16 i worked
on mindset for myself and i'm such a
believer in mindset is almost everything
and it just happened to be a set of
circumstances i was riding my bike with
one of my best friends at 16 and she was
run over by a car and killed in front of
me
and then a few months later my dad left
home and my parents separated and
ultimately got divorced and when my dad
moved out he came into my bedroom and he
handed me a cassette tape series called
how to be a no limit person by wayne
dyer
and he said sweetie i wish i discovered
this when i was your age instead of the
age of 40. and then he moved out
and so i started listening to this how
to be a no limit person which was
talking about visualization law of
attraction
not caring about what other people think
about you
the fear you know not being consumed by
the fear of failure
and it just the clouds parted for me and
i thought you know i've spent a lot of
time being taught what to think but no
one's really teaching me how to think
and at 16 that was so incredibly
important so in this digital platform
it's kind of passing on a lot of these
insights that deal with mindset
that i think is the real reason that
spanx exists when you first launched in
the very beginning the features were
sort of profile with like a profile
photo in your name and who you are and
also you included things like what house
you lived in um what dorm you lived in
um and what courses you were taking
do you think it would have worked
without that would it have been enough
just to have profiles
you know it's a really interesting
question and we certainly since then
have evolved and wanted to make a more
general service so we've so we've
dropped some of those things
but i remember um there's this early
debate that dustin and i had where
we had to do some manual work for every
school that we that we released facebook
at and um in order to do that we
basically went through and we parsed the
course catalogs of the schools to make
sure that the data was clean
and um and i remember having this debate
where dustin was like we could just
expand so much faster
or it would just be easier i mean we
were bound by server capacity but it
would be easier to launch new schools um
if we didn't have to have course
catalogs for each school and we just had
this really long debate
about what quality meant for us and the
the community that we wanted to
establish and and the culture of it and
um you know in retrospect you know maybe
it wouldn't have had a huge difference
on on how things played out but it
definitely kind of set this tone where
there's a lot of kind of clean data on
facebook you can rely on it it feels
like a college specific thing yeah which
was valuable early on for setting the
culture even though obviously since then
we've grown beyond that and you know i
mean i think you guys in the projects
that you work on you're gonna have a lot
of similar questions right i mean
there's the famous 80 20 rule where you
know you get 80 of the benefit by doing
20 of the work uh but
you can't just 80 20 everything right i
mean there have to be certain things
that you just are the best at right and
that you go way further than anyone else
had to establish this kind of quality
bar and have your product be the best
thing that's out there so you know
whether we had to do that one or had to
do something we had to do i think enough
of those things or else we just wouldn't
have been the best service out there i
haven't had any existential crisis knock
on wood i find i don't want to jinx
anything
but we've had a lot of uh
kind of
dramatic events i remember
um there early on
we only had 125 employees
when barnes and noble who the big united
states bookseller
opened their online website to compete
against us barnesandnoble.com we had
about a two-year window we opened in 95
they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be destroyed by this much
larger company we had 125 employees
and
60 million dollars a year in annual
sales 60 million with an m
and that uh and barnes and noble at the
time had 30 000 employees
and about 3 billion in sales
so
they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were very negative about
amazon and the one that's most minimal
or memorable was just amazon.toast
and
and so i called it all hands meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and because
it was so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor
that literally everybody's parents were
calling and saying you know are you okay
is the you know it's usually the moms um
calling and asking their children are
you gonna be okay so and i said look you
know it it's okay to be afraid um but
don't be afraid of our competitors
because they're never going to send us
any money be afraid of our customers and
if we just stay focused on them in
in in instead of
obsessing over this big competitor that
we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to double down on
the customer
satisfying them not just satisfying them
delighting them my question for you is
as you look back on your career in the
space industry what has been the most
surprising or unexpected challenge that
you faced and along those lines if you
were to go back in time and talk to your
20 year old self would you do anything
differently
go back in time
to your 20 year old self
i mean i think i'd
if i could i think it would make a far
fewer mistakes obviously if i could go
like here's a list of all the dumb
things you're about to do please do not
do them
yeah wouldn't we
be a very long list i'm like
here let me
write it down or something you know
i mean it's hindsight's 2020. so it's
hard to say
um
i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i had a lot count
honestly
um
i mean some of these things i just wish
i like
like that's
simple sort of mantra
management by rhyming i mean it worked
for homer okay
um the management by rhyming is
the thing i'm saying like if but if the
schedule's long the design is wrong
we've overcomplicated the design many
times
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design
um
with the acid test being
how long will it take to
for this to fly
and if it's going to take a long time
don't do it do something else i think we
we need to push for radical
breakthroughs um
and if you don't push for radical
breakthroughs you're not going to get
radical outcomes
um and that that does mean taking risks
um
and and yeah
common sense that
the if you take a big risk in order to
have a big reward there must be a big
risk it's most the time
you cannot find a
big reward for small risk that's those
are rare
so you're going to have some
proportionality or the risk can reward
first day i went to school i was in a
classroom
by the time i was uh
you know six years old didn't go to
school i was six years old because i
lived my grandmother at that time sure
but she had taught me how to read read
the bible bible stories
so i went into the classroom
knowing nicodemus
shadrach meshach and abednego
i could spell all of those words
i thought i was you know i was preaching
to the to my kindergarten teacher
so
she was like who is this girl
so
i was never placed in an environment
where i was ever made to feel inferior i
always felt like i'm the smartest kid in
this room
and because i was never placed in a
never put in a position where i was made
to feel
less than i didn't grow up feeling less
than you know and the rest as they say
is history and the rest they say is
history and it's all about what you
believe you know i say this to
uh when i do something on my network now
called life class
the fundamental key to success
is what you believe
is true for yourself not what you want
not what you desire it's what do you
believe
you know you can say i want to i want to
be the most successful person in the
world but if you believe that there's a
glass ceiling and you're going to have a
hard time kicking through that glass
ceiling you will be defined by the glass
ceiling and
the great beauty and gift of my life is
that i was never defined by the box that
other people tried to put me in what
would you say is the best advice that
you could give other people from what
you learned about making their first
million bucks so say somebody's making
six figures scaling up and that's just
do the math you know what's what's first
of all do you want to make a million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
percent difference between those two
questions right so specificity and the
goal you want to make everybody's go
everybody watching is going to make a
million dollars i mean if you live
25 years you're going to make a million
dollars 25 times 40 000 bucks bang you
made a million dollars if that's your
goal so this is what i talked about in
the 10-x rule the goals people are
setting
are incorrect and that's why people give
up on their goals
because
i know so many guys that hit a million
dollars like i've had so many people
come to me and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice
yeah it got comfortable almost yeah a
lot of guys in network marketing tell me
this like was in network marketing i
became a million dollar producer
just lost it because the goal was wrong
the goal was wrong first of all it
wasn't your goal
anybody's got a million dollar target
it's not your goal you adopted this goal
this idea from somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
the chance is a number ending in zero is
almost mathematical what a great point
what a great point so it's a lazy
concept you just adopted somebody else's
idea i want to be a millionaire would do
you have even done the math do the math
on a million dollars it's no money this
is what people they they like god hate
grant
because your target was a million
you're struggling making 200. you think
a million is impossible
you don't want me to tell you the truth
and the truth is it is no money as soon
as you get it i read the book the
millionaire next door almost everybody
read that book back in the 90s
it was the best book for me
because it taught me
i don't want to be a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck
i don't want a ford truck man
right i got to buy a ford truck a used
ford truck f-150
so one day i could be a millionaire
and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack to my office every
day
not drink coffee at the shop
in order to be a millionaire well the
reason i knew that was not good for me
was because my dad died at 52
with a little bit of money
and i'm like i don't want to die
with money when i'm old
i want to have enough money
and that that undid everything for me i
want financial freedom i don't want to
hit a quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on what their
spending is or what their apartment cost
or what the mortgage is rather or what
their kids need rather than i want
freedom
i don't want financial literacy
i want financial freedom
you know so i hear people say oh we need
to teach financial literacy no you need
to teach financial freedom the
possibility of it what would i need how
much
you know this whole cash flow thing that
i talk about all the time cash flow is
the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number two
weeks ago i went i went uh plant only
plant-based plant-based i was afraid i
dropped the meat dude that's so i want
to do i did that for a week last week
yeah and i thought amazing i had a lot
of more gas just from all the plants i
think but i was cleaning it out that's
really too much information for me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like and less inflammation less pain
yeah i had noticed i have a little bit
of inflammation in in my hands but that
hadn't hadn't changed but
the plant-based thing i watched the game
the the game changing show yeah
and uh when he said
dude you're eating the middleman
like when i heard that that was enough
for me right eating the middleman you're
eating the middleman
meaning the cow the cow eats the grass
right you go eat go right
the source is the grass yeah and as soon
as i heard that i'm like what am i doing
eating the middleman
i ain't a middleman guy i want to go
directly to the source where all the
energy's at yeah i mean like like i
didn't that was the line in the show
that did me wow and i had been thinking
about it too i've eaten meat for 60
years i grew up on bacon
four pieces of bacon every day so good
uh oh yeah totally
the eggs i i have not eaten any meat
in 12 days
and my energy is
this all day long oh wow
3 30 in the afternoon for the last 25
years i crash at 3 30. hard crash i mean
like
i'll see you guys uh call me later okay
what you doing at 3 30. i got i got a
meeting yeah and that meeting was on
that nap dude and when i hit it i'm
talking coma
[Laughter]
deep sleep
better than
sleep at night sometimes it would be 30
minutes sometimes it'd be an hour and a
half
like comatose 12 days i can't take a nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
so i get my energy do you think you're
gonna stick with this do you think
you'll have meat sometimes you think i
mean i'm not i'm not like i'm not a
fanatic guy so yeah so it's not a little
meat here and there or something i'm
just gonna eat what makes me feel best
yeah so i don't care if it was meat if
it was pork it was bacon but right now
um
as long as i can find the greens
and i haven't met i haven't missed the
meat wow
my digestion's better
you know
my energy is great
so
i don't know man i actually think you
should think twice before starting
certain types of businesses so i think
um there are probably too many bad
businesses getting started and not
enough good ones so that's it's um you
know i don't think there's i don't think
there's anything about entrepreneurship
per se
that is um
that is is good you know i was telling
one of my friends a few years ago i was
asking him what do you want to be doing
in five or ten years oh it's really
clear i want to be an entrepreneur
that's like saying i want to be rich i
want to be famous um and i don't think
uh i don't think those are those are
good things being rich and famous um
they're not good as direct goals like if
if you if you have that as your sole
goal you're unlikely to i think really
uh really succeed and so i think you
become an entrepreneur because you're
working on an important problem nobody
else is working on i think you should
start a business if you have uh
something if you're if you're working on
a problem that otherwise would not get
solved the packaging what am i going to
do for the packaging i knew i thought as
a consumer i didn't know anything else
i'd never actually taken a marketing
class either in my life but i knew as a
consumer i was frustrated i was going
into the hosiery departments and
everything looked the same it was the
same beige package or the same way
package with the same half naked woman
that been on there for 30 years
and
i couldn't tell what i was buying so i
said to myself i'm gonna do this
different i want it to be my favorite
color red no one had ever done red in
the hosiery space before i want wanted
to be bold stand out i knew that if i
got a chance to be on the shelf with no
money to advertise it had to jump out
and say i'm new i'm different try me so
i put three animated illustrated cartoon
women on the package which had also
never been done before there had only
ever been photography on these poetry
packages i was working on it every night
after work on my friend's computer she
had just finished
graphic design school so i would come
home and we would sit side by side and i
was cutting out lips and eyes and i was
very you know excited about how to make
it design wise i wanted it to feel like
you were buying a present for yourself
instead of a commodity that we dreaded
well growing up my dad used to encourage
my brother and me to fail so at the
dinner table he would actually ask us
what did you fail at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go and high-five me
and
what it was such a gift what he was
doing i didn't realize it at the time
but he was redefining failure for me and
so failure became not about the outcome
but about not trying
and
so you know the fear of failure as we
all know as entrepreneurs is one of the
greatest fears in life it's one of the
things that stops us in our tracks and
keeps us from trying something
and so i you know i incorporate that in
my philosophy at spanx we have we
celebrate failures we talk about them we
have oops meetings where i'll announce
the oops that i have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach
theme songs to our oops
and we'll play them in front of the
whole company but i think it's just so
important to try to get the people that
you work with to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of i want to protect my job and feel
like i'm not safe if i make mistakes i
have seen
people and
it happens to everybody no matter what
it is i've seen people rip you apart on
both sides
for both
how how does that
what what what
how does that drive you does that drive
you at all does that does that one
political correctness of having to
conform and being what everybody says
you're supposed to be
does that
drive you at all
well it's it's uh you try you try to you
try to ignore it to some extent you know
you try um
not to um you but you don't you know you
don't try to
you don't try to put yourself into any
of these um very uncomfortable straight
jackets and you know you don't want um
and i think that's
that's what's so uh pernicious about all
the identity politics that uh that um
you know we we all have to be
in in this category we're all the same i
think people are all different we're all
you know we're all we're all you know
i'm somewhat idiosyncratic but i think
all of us are all of us are
idiosyncratic in different ways and i
think i think this is a this is
something that um most people experience
that they're being put into boxes way
more than they're comfortable you know
there's this interview question i always
like asking people tell me something
that's true that very few people agree
with you on
and um it's a very hard question to
answer
um and it's it's not because people
don't have answers they actually have
lots of answers to it it's because
they're uncomfortable answering it in
the context of an interview because um
you know if it has the answer has to be
something the person asking you won't
agree and we're always nervous about
doing that we always want to fit in and
this uh this this pressure to fit in is
uh
is is really powerful one time you know
as you know i went to indiana and
in dallas in the mid 90s you know when
when we had a good basketball team
we we literally would when we wanted to
listen to our big games like indiana
purdue go hoosiers um
we would call somebody in bloomington
who would put a radio next to a speaker
phone and dial us and we'd sit on the
other side listening over a speakerphone
drinking our beer and whipping it up or
doing whatever and the internet was just
starting to happen and now i'm a tech
geek and i'm like into all of it and
we're like
there's got to be a better way to do
this and so one of my buddies from
indiana todd wagner was like look we've
been thinking about this and i'm like no
i'll figure it out i'm a networking guy
now and so we
looked for ways to
stream indiana basketball we called it
net casting back then over the brand new
internet and so i went out and bought a
packard bell 90 megahertz computer and
an isdn line and downloaded all the
software and i said you know what i'm
going to figure it out
and lo and behold by
oh golly early 1995 we had figured out a
way to
we would we took these eight-hour vcrs
and connected it to a local radio
station record them we'd bring them back
go through this process called encoding
and put it up on this website we called
audionet and then i'd go to any online
forum aol prodigy compuserve uunet
whatever it was or you use use usenet
and i like if you're interested in
dallas sports at all because we haven't
gotten to indiana yet if you're
interested in dallas sports go to this
website audionet and back then you had a
dial-up modem you had to download the
software called tcpip and you had to
have software from your internet
provider which meant that so few people
knew how to use it we had no idea if it
would work or not
but all of a sudden audionet went from
10 people a day to 100 people to a
thousand people a day and as we added
radio stations they're getting calls
from all over the world from people who
are listening to their shows on demand
not even lined and then we worked with a
company that put together live software
company called zing
and we made it live and then everything
changed and that's really when streaming
was born
and we just grew that and then in 1998
we got into video changed the name to
broadcast.com
went public and it was the biggest ipo
in the history of the stock market at
the time um and then we sold it to yahoo
at what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for what was
the point where you guys said like let's
do this like what was the well we were
planning to do it because i knew the
business i was in marketing sales and
structure and had connections with uh
product development
and i didn't do hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world
very advanced in what he did however he
didn't do business it was a perfect
combination these two guys together
we're just the best of friends and we
knew we could do it uh obviously we
started out with nothing we made the
decision let's just let's just make this
happen and as you will see and your
guests will see when they look at good
fortune the movie and it's on itunes
it's on amazon all those when they look
at it it's the whole story of starting
in america with nothing a couple times
and making things happen because of what
you believe in but the important thing
is even we had nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first company to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state wow or other things we do why not
shake your hand to that sure you betcha
but i applaud you that's awesome it's
still going on that one our goal was to
get we started with four employees uh
and our goal was to get to 50 employees
and the goal really was not so much to
make a lot of money i wanted i wanted to
me a lot of money in those days was i
want to own a house
i want to have a nice car and
i wanted to
work with interesting people and do
interesting things and i thought if i
could control my own environment have a
small consulting company and oracle
started out as a software consulting
company we work for tandem computer if
anyone remembers those guys we work for
ibm we work for a lot of
different tech companies in silicon
valley doing contract programming fixed
price contract programming and we did
pretty well
actually and and again the idea was just
to have a a small software contract
software company
a bunch of yeah we thought we were hot
shot programmers and we thought we could
make a decent living doing just that and
quite by accident we built a product
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm quite grumpy
[Music]